[Music]
it's one of my favorite moves and i've
made some videos about it
is this turning with in spins
on a wall plane so fluid so graceful
yeah i like it the anti-spin correlate
it would be turning the other way with
four petal
anti-spin and i find that
much much harder here i'll show you what
it looks like when i try to do it
which isn't very graceful yet
and that's about as good at it as i am
now
now it could be i mean the easier thing
would be doing
not on a wall plane or i'm just shifting
planes way easier
boop boop
but this is the kind of move where when
i try to do it on a wall plane
and that means the poi are staying on
this plane
and i'm turning my ear then the back of
my head to the poi
then my other ear then facing it
[Music]
that takes me through sort of this mind
gym
where i have to know what the player
doing behind my back
as it switches from clockwise or
counterclockwise and that's really hard
and sometimes when i encounter things
like that i think you know what
that's a blind spot and i bet if i
get some light into that blind spot
something's going to open up with my
ability to
improv and move freely
and i set out to do that a long time ago
like this is a move
that 15 years ago
i encountered it i mean i came up with
that idea on my own
[Music]
and i thought yeah i'm going to dominate
that i'm going to get really good at
that
and i didn't i never got
super fluid with it um but i'm circling
back to it now
and i'm inviting you to try it with me
the warning is it's not easy on the
shoulders
so if you're going to try to learn this
air on the side of relaxing rather than
trying to get everything perfect
and spend a lot of time trying to figure
out how to make sure your shoulders
are not going into super crazy weird
extreme positions
easier said than done so for me that's
going to look like doing a lot of
one ply at a time
as i try to figure out what that blind
spot is
and how i can relax through it
then the other arm and then putting them
together so i invite you to explore that
i will come back to this as i get better
at it
and with my ideas of how to polish it
and
possibly ideas of what opens up upon
getting fluid with this if you're
learning this
definitely learn the in spin first
[Music]
before you try the anti-spin in both
cases start with lots of circles
really take your time same with
anti-spin at first do 10 circles
whatever the planes are going to be
really hard at first
and then eventually it goes one
two three four one two three
four you could also do four circle
versions um
and that would be where each poi makes
five petals
um one pointing up one pointing down
uh we'll come back to all of that i had
a good night practicing last night
so i've got some cool stuff that i'm
going to be working on
let me know if that's interesting yeah
and we'll proceed into the summer of poi
as crazy stuff happens in the world it
all seems very important but we've got
to move
flow
[Music]